[Music]
so I'm trying to make this passage clear
first I would organize for myself what's
going on especially rhythmically because
when you're not playing rhythmically it
won't sound clear so here I wanna hear
and then I would you zoom in completely
and and it's easier to hear very
critically in small chunks something
that the teacher I work with last year
showed me is to be efficient with the
fingers so in this case you would take
all your fingers and hover them about
equal distance above the keys and as
you're playing a note you would keep it
down and then bring it right back up to
where it was before when you play the
next note and make that movement and
very hard for me because I'm not
practice that
[Music]
so this teaches you not to waste
movement by lifting your fingers first
and then pressing them down and doing
that curling motion that I like so this
is a weird thing I'm sure people have
done this in passing like when it's cold
out to warm your fingers I think the
main thing though is to practice